MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the
show on Google Developers
Live about startups.
My name is Martin Omander,
and I'm joined here today
by Don Dodge, longtime
investor and startup advocate.
Welcome, Don.
DON DODGE: Thank you.
Great to be here.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So you've invested
in many companies.
And we keep hearing, or
at least I keep hearing,
that investors look
at the team a lot.
Not just the idea, but at the
team in a startup before they
invest.
What specifically
are they looking for?
DON DODGE: They look for a
couple of things in a team.
One is balance.
So a technical co-founder,
a business co-founder, maybe
a design co-founder that's
really strong in design.
Or maybe someone who's strong
in marketing and social media
and that kind of thing.
You need all of those
things, and it's rare
that one person possesses
all of those qualities.
So the first thing
they're looking for
is a balance of co-founders
and capabilities.
Second thing they look
for is experience.
So do you have experience in
building scalable systems?
Or do you have experience
in launching products
across multiple market segments?
Or do you have domain experience
in this market, so you
understand what the problems
are and that kind of thing?
So it's those types of things
you look for in founders.
And then the most
important thing is passion.
Do you have passion
for this idea?
Is it something that
you have experience in?
So a lot of times I
hear investors say,
why did you start this company?
What is the idea?
The reason they
ask that question
is to probe a little bit
on where your passion is.
Is this a problem that
you've experienced
and that you have passion about?
If you do then your odds of
success are slightly better.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So what if you have
everything lined up?
You have a team that is a
good balance of business
and technology, good
domain experience.
And what if you have
somebody on the team who
has done startups and
been successful before?
Does that mean you're
going to succeed?
DON DODGE: Good question.
So the question about, are
serial entrepreneurs more
successful than first
time entrepreneurs?
Generally, yes.
If you've had an experience
once or twice before,
your chances of success
are slightly higher.
Even if those prior
experiences were failures.
The reason is because--
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, even
if they were failures.
DON DODGE: Yes, yes.
Now, if you've had
multiple startups before,
and they were successful,
your odds of success
go up a little higher.
But even if you've had
multiple experiences,
and one or two of
them were failures,
you still have a
slightly better chance
of success than a first
time entrepreneur.
Because you've seen
some of those problems
that come up in every startup.
So every startup
is going to face
some of these
problems that happen.
And if you've been
through them before,
at least you know
what to look for.
And you see the red flags
earlier and say, oh, OK,
I have seen that problem before.
I didn't do it right last time.
So I know not to do that.
I'm going to try
something different.
So all of those things
together give you
a slightly better
chance of success.
MARTIN OMANDER: A
slightly better chance.
So not a much
better chance then.
DON DODGE: No.
MARTIN OMANDER: No?
Most startups fail.
50% of them fail completely.
So what you're trying to
do, as an entrepreneur
and as an investor, is
increase your chances
of success 5% or 10%.
If you can do that, if
you can be successful
55% of the time, 60% of
the time as an investor,
you're doing great.
As an entrepreneur,
if you can just
increase your odds of success.
Because there are no
guarantees in this business.
But if you can increase your
odds of success a little bit,
that's good.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Even a little bit counts.
DON DODGE: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I've seen
many startup teams, founders,
they have this great idea.
They think they're
alone with it.
They are very excited about it.
And then they hear that another
company's doing it, maybe
another startup that
is better funded.
Or they might hear that
somebody tried a similar idea
in the past and failed.
And they are disheartened.
Should they be?
DON DODGE: No, they
shouldn't be disheartened.
They should learn from that.
So as an entrepreneur
you want to look
at the competitive
landscape and see,
is there anyone else trying
to do what I'm doing now?
Generally there is.
So understand--
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so you're
seldom alone with your idea?
DON DODGE: Almost rarely.
If you're alone, I would
be even more skeptical.
Because if no one
else is doing this,
then maybe this isn't a market.
So typically there is
competition, either currently
or someone has tried this
in the past and failed.
So what you want to do is
learn from that and say,
all right, here are the
approaches that they took.
Here are the strategies
that they had.
Here the feature sets
that they focused on.
Why did those fail?
Or why did they succeed?
You need to do the
homework to understand
why the competition
failed and how
you're going to
avoid that failure.
Or how you're going to
do something better,
maybe the same
approach but you have
new wrinkles and new
approaches to make it work.
So if you haven't done the
homework to sort that out
and to understand what
the competition is,
why they succeeded in some
cases and why they failed,
then your chances
of success go down.
So make sure you
do your homework
and understand why
something failed.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Understand what failed.
OK, great.
Thank you very much, Don.
Thanks for sharing your
experience with us.
DON DODGE: Thanks.
Good to be here.
MARTIN OMANDER: And when
I'm not sitting here
I'm a developer here
at Google, writing
internal tools for my team.
And I always use the
Google Cloud Platform.
Because that allows
me to actually write
code and be productive,
and not deal
with system administration.
And we now have an offer
where you viewers can
get started on the
Google Cloud platform
and get a $2,000 credit.
So you can really try it out,
see how it works for you.
The details are onscreen.
That's it for today.
Please keep those comments
on YouTube coming.
And we will address and answer
them in future episodes.
Thanks, bye.